>> Chris: TONIGHT, AN UPDATE
TO A STORY WE BOUGHT YOU EARLIER
THIS WEEK ABOUT AN AMERICAN
FAMILY WITH TWO MEMBERS BEING
HELD IN IRAN.
NATIONAL SECURITY CORRESPONDENT
JENNIFER GRIFFIN TELLS US THE
U.S.’S DEMANDING IRAN RELEASE A
81-YEAR-OLD AMERICAN IT PUT BACK
IN PRISON THIS WEEK AFTER GIVING
HIM A FOUR DAY LEAVE FOR HEALTH
REASONS.
>> FAMILY OF 81-YEAR-OLD
-- IMPRISONED BY IRAN AFTER THE
NUCLEAR DEAL.
IN A CRUEL TWIST, THE IRANIAN
REGIME RELEASED HIM FOR FOUR
DAYS BECAUSE HIS HEALTH WAS
FAILING.
THIS WEEK, THEY SENT HIM BACK TO
IRAN’S NOTORIOUS AVON PRISON.
>> I WAS STUNNED WHEN OUT OF THE
BLUE CALLED MY MOM AND DEMANDED
THAT MY FATHER WILL REPORT BACK
IMMEDIATELY.
>> HIS SON GREW UP IN
WHITE PLAINS, NEW YORK, AND IS
LOBBYING CONGRESS FOR HELP.
HE SAYS HIS FATHER FACES A
VIRTUAL DEATH SENTENCE AND
DESCRIBED HIS BROTHER’S TORTURE
IN SALARY CONFINEMENT.
>> HE’S BEEN SHOCKED BY TASERS.
TIED WITH HIM AND WITH THE
THREAT OF ELECTRIC SHOCK.
>> WE ARE DEEPLY DISAPPOINTED IN
THE FACT HE HAS BEEN RETURNED TO
PRISON.
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT HIS
HEALTH.
CALLING FOR UNCONDITIONAL
RELEASE.
>> NAMAZI WAS LURED BACK TO IRAN
WITH THE PROMISE OF SEEING HIS
SON IN PRISON THREE YEARS AGO
WHILE ON VACATION IN IRAN.
>> I HAVE NO DOUBTS, THEM BEING
AMERICANS.
>> HE WORKED FOR UNICEF FOR MORE
THAN TWO DECADES.
HIS COLLEAGUES RELEASED A
STATEMENT AFTER HE WAS SENT BACK
TO PRISON THIS WEEK.
"WE CONTINUE TO BE CONCERNED
ABOUT HIS THE TEARING HEALTH AND
PLEAD WITH THE IRANIAN
GOVERNMENT TO GRANT HIM A FULL
AND UNCONDITIONAL RELIEF ON
HUMANITARIAN GROUNDS."
NAMAZIS ARE NOT THE ONLY
AMERICANS BEING UNJUSTLY
DETAINED BY IRAN FOR THERE IS
PRINCETON GRADUATE STUDENT
SHEILA WONG, AND BASADARI, WHO
RAN AN ART GALLERY IN TEHRAN
END.
>> COME PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS A